alors il vit comme votre groupe
s'appelait laisse tout est question de
choisir les nuls je vous faire
l'interview nul on ne bouge pas pendant
le génial on ne bouge pas on en retire
en oeuvre ne bouge pas on en legging al
youm of the rings de mieux éclats j'ai
bougé par la musique non mais caf au
légué est ce que vous préférez votre
père votre mère phare de joie âge et à
le faire est vivante et vivant est ce
que vous préférez staline ou hitler
people3 mes vêtements
le provocateur que c'est vous partez
trois ans dans un vaisseau spatial est
ce que vous préférez partir fuir in
space ship
est-ce que vous préféré partir avec
madonna mariah carey jennifer lopez
britney spears ou janet jackson le père
d'une fille le pen les pieds sur terre
d'accord alors vous devez partir sur une
île déserte
est-ce que vous préféré partir avec un
mec très beau ou avec une fille très
laide bigorre qui fit rêver oui les mecs
très beau jeu c'est vraiment me casse
pieds et vous question on peut parier
partir les km très beau une fille très
laide
ça changerait bien il dit le mot le plus
con en amour
est-ce que c'est merci encore
ou oui oui bon nous miner votre
condition préférées est ce que c'est
d'être peint ces mordus piqué mon âge
avait entendu vous le saurez les filles
si vous deviez payer une ville de la
carte laquelle j'en étais à west
hollywood
quel est l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
les coins daisy diane sawyer espérait
mourir comme otis redding dans un crash
d'avion comme john lennon abattu à bout
portant
comme john bonham le batteur de led
zeppelin qui est mort en s'étouffant
dans son vomi et oui je ne viens que je
sais c'est la vérité c'est l'histoire du
rock'n'roll j'aime bien c'est comme ça
et oui ou comme janis joplin d'une
overdose quoi ya pas de primaire à un
accident d'avion comme otis redding dans
l'accident d'avion aucune culpabilité
pas d'erreur et guy si vous étiez en
vente dans un sex shop vous voudriez
être quoi
à à un soutien-gorge et bouazzi vient de
tromper science si vous étiez en vente
dans un sex-shop voudrait être quoi une
crème monsieur séville dernière question
explique offre une question stupide mais
qui n'est pas de moi celle là aimez-vous
les chiens oui oui j'ai un chien
mythique encore comment il s'appelle
selon ba iggy pop ils s'aiment option
nouveau cd rom ou lé jodie plats subit
la bouteille
mchugh pantomime merci d'être venus
hip-hop et à bientôt et garder la faire